looks like we use a sharpie marker for
my eyeliner and apparently the roots are
playing today new year new me no hi my
name is very top if you do not know now
you know your life is different now it
is the beginning of 2018 some say it's
the beginning of the end this Bloody
Mary concept being more welcomed by more
restaurants across all the land last
year was not my finest year here that my
brother and I were really obsessed with
that show The Nanny was probably my
finest year you didn't get it did you
miss the champagne okay but this year I
have really high hopes have a nice named
hope and she likes to she's I know she's
a baby
about drugs like I think all of us want
the beginning of any new year is to do
better than the year before and I really
really want to do that so I thought I
would share with you guys some of my new
year's resolutions
I want to regularly upload videos oh
that's hard I want to try to experiment
with formats like anal I guess content
you know maybe a scripted series we're
just uh I want to create more of a
routine for myself french fries cheese
curds gravy
that's poutine just shitty millennial
that's a poutine but like a bunch of
them that's a poutine stop it that's a
few see this is stupid
that's a new meme oh my god I want to
start responding to things sooner oh
that's good cuz you're terrible duh
yourself I want to start to get out of
my comfort zone oh but not like I'm
gonna start doing music out of my
comfort zone don't worry
oh my god I mean like porn oh thank god
I want to start taking better care of
the things that I own oh that's good
like your brain ya know your body my
what you're a doll she's you're
somewhere okay then what do you own that
you are going to take care of my grudges
I own so many of them I just want to
make sure that I take good care of them
so I can just maintain them forever oh
they sure also want to start to read
more
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay that's it for this video guys if
you liked it please make sure that you
subscribe because things are gonna
change a little bit this year I've been
on YouTube for so long and I'm just I'm
I gotta change things up to make myself
happy and hopefully you guys do so my
potential thought is that my body is
functional but also that for the last
few years I've been trying to upload
videos Monday Wednesday and Friday so I
thought let's change it up this year and
what about Tuesday Thursday doing three
videos a week I've realized has started
to like hurt my heart and makes me less
enthusiastic about posting so I'm hoping
maybe two videos a week might clear my
brain and give me more creative space to
come up with some really fun things so
let me know in the comments down below
and you think Tuesday and Thursday are
good upload days and let me know in the
comments down below what your new year's
resolutions are whether they are true or
not just let me know because I don't
know improvement could be a great name
for a porn I'm just saying